ukrainians huddled inside a kindergarten
last week thinking they'd be safe
instead a child and two civilians were
killed
this is drone footage of the
kindergarten showing a man lying on the
ground blood pooling around him and
damage to the school in multiple
locations
this weapon from kharkiv lying atop ashy
snow
this week the international criminal
court or icc announced it would
investigate if war crimes have been
committed in ukraine this is
a reminder to all
factions to all parties to the conflict
that they must conduct themselves in
compliance with the laws of war
the
drilling down of course the obligation
is to conduct credible investigations
which means there's no
destination
that is predetermined
we have to get to the truth amnesty
international says this is just a
sampling of the evidence it is collected
of russia's suspected use of cluster
munitions since it invaded ukraine last
week we have
investigated seven cases in depth
where uh cluster munitions and other
ballistic missiles that are prohibited
under international law have struck
schools hospitals
medical centers uh places that are not
supposed to be hit by
weapons because they're protected
as civilian objects under international
law
in 2014 human rights watch accused the
ukrainian military of widespread use of
cluster munitions while fighting
pro-russian rebels in donetsk
political analyst dmitry babich says
russia demanded an investigation but it
went nowhere
unfortunately
international judicial bodies are not
independent not only from powerful
governments but also from
public opinion you know right now public
opinion is very much against russia and
it sees this tragedy that is going on in
ukraine in black and white terms
i think the story is not black and white
when fired cluster munitions create a
kind of fireworks of small bombs
scattering indiscriminately across
several hundred meters
those that don't explode leave landmines
often killing children who pick up the
small balls left behind
more than 100 countries have agreed to
ban their use russia and ukraine have
not
natasha ghanim al jazeera